طائره بدون طيار صينيه
تفوق سرعه الصوت
تستخدم لعمليه الرصد والتجسس
كشفت عنها الصين عام 2019
قادره على القيام بالتجسس الاستراتيجي
مداها يسمح لها بالوصول لتايوان وكوريا
الجنوبيه
ارسلتها بكين لقاعده الوان العسكريه
القاعده تقع في محافظه الوان شرقي البلاد
على مسافه قصيره من تايوان تم تعديل
المدرجي لكي يستقبل المسيره المتطوره في
الاسابيع الاخيره قامت مسيرات صينيه
بالطيران حول الجزيره هدف العمليه كان
اثبات قدرات بكين على التجسس ورصد الاهداف
التايوانيه
لتوجيه ضربات صاروخيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات